what were you saying the other day we
gotta we gotta make a show on only fans
um what was i saying we've gotta we
gotta be like the first network show
that's like
that's right oh yeah right
yeah because we could fund it ourselves
yeah
yeah we we have people pre-sign up or
whatever then they're already paying
monthly
and then we can we can produce a like a
legitimate tv show and have it just be
on only fans yeah we
we make the first episode and people pay
for that and then based on the earnings
for that that dictates the next episode
yes and so on and so forth 100
what would the story be uh just
something like really pg
and innocent like maybe you know uh a
child's
no sorry go ahead go ahead not go ahead
no no you can no
maybe like something like milo notice
you remember that oh okay okay okay i
was gonna say the story about some like
dogs that get lost
oh man so it's not even about come back
home no maybe it's just about pets yeah
like it's like a stuart little story
yeah stuart little trying to find his
new car
yeah maybe okay i was gonna go even more
like
you know like cw like a man wakes up
from a coma
and he tries to piece his life back
together and in the process of doing
that
he finds love it's like really
really kind of deep and like damn like
so far from sexual
like like in like a you know a
spiritually uplifting way
yeah you know yeah yeah i love it
you know the show could be like um and
the pew
people keep waiting for the for the
sexualness to happen because it's
only fans but it never does never never
never it and it's like uh
the title could be something really
really deep like tomorrow's not lost
yeah and it's [ __ ] army hammer is the
lead
i love it dude just you know little
what are you watching oh it's the show
on only fans
oh damn what's her name no no no it's uh
it's tomorrow's not lost it's a
it's featuring army hammer yeah it's
really good actually it's really good
yeah
this this is him waking up from the coma
check it out it'll be like that quibby
show
yeah exactly yeah yeah exactly
you'd be like army hammer oh does he got
a hammer yeah i don't know you never see
him you never see him naked
he's just a really emotionally like it's
really uh like the
depth of this character is fantastic ooh
depth like you mean he'd be hidden in
depth
no no no no it's not sexual at all it's
i'm saying
ew just the emotional weight of this guy
is fantastic
it's unbelievable it's it's it's amazing
how
how much he can just project i mean the
the character is just
oozing oozing
oozing just you know
just he's just such a rich yeah yeah
keep going keep going
ah damn dude or or we we we we recreate
the social network but it's the guys who
created only fans
yeah that's probably going to happen i
bet yeah
yeah oh yeah that would be good sell
that [ __ ] for a billion dollars
yeah make a billion dollars and there
was it's one guy i think
i think it's just one dude is it hold on
movie about the start of porn we've
brought this up before
fans middle senator
yeah timothy stokely
that's who it is my brother's 37 years
old
36 acres 37 you cut off yeah damn yeah
37 years old he's a banker's son
nice nice
oh danny harwood became the first brit
to make 1 million euros from the site
since joining in 2019
wow
that's crazy man yeah isn't that crazy
to know that like you could just
like you could just be born with a
million dollar set of
um bazingas or cannons or you know you
got a hammer that's worth a million
bucks
it's got to feel pretty good right yeah
yeah oh yeah
i was thinking about that like with
fighters like when when a guy like
conor mcgregor becomes like huge uh
not like his dick but yeah what do you
mean
i was thinking about when fighters get
hard you know yeah exactly
no like when they when they when they
blow up and like
they like look at their hands and that
that feeling of being like
damn my hands are literally worth like
25 million dollars yeah
crazy yeah that is pretty wild
just swinging your neck around in the
mirror
who's a millionaire you are slapping it
against your thighs
you are 10 grand 10 grand 10 grand 10
grand 10 grand
oh time to go to work buddy 50 g's 50
g's
yeah i don't know this is like the fifth
episode in a row we've talked about only
fans but
it's actually crazy that it's been
around only since 2016.
yeah sorry i just had a thought about
calling your insurance company like
you know they there used to be that myth
that jlo had her ass insured
yeah getting your dick in shirt after
like your first big only fans check
yeah i'm gonna have to add another
member to my policy
nice and it's got one eye okay so
nice vision impaired i wouldn't say
impaired
yeah there's nothing impaired about this
you might be yeah yeah
later you might be filing as well yeah
you might be filing a claim after taking
a taking a ride with this bad boy
you might be impaled let's just say okay
how old is the member
well you know he's my age but uh boy is
he strong
okay it's my dick
oh right yeah my penis it's my penis
it's incredibly large
oh my god mr mr stokely built only fans
after he previously created a bdsm and
fetish like
glamwarship.com what was that
let's see i'm gonna ctrl c ctrl v that
no longer available oh interesting
you're no longer around
huh you should buy this domain client
just restart the business back
up this is our note that's our new merch
website
yeah you want some new
merchantworship.com
in the spirit of the original creators
we're making everything out of leather
leather snapbacks leather that's not
really that crazy
um sounds dope though yeah
uh yeah there's nothing really crazy
that you can do with leather anyway